bonjour françois bonjour cabinet bonjour
julie salut qu'à prier pendant ce temps
n'est pas aujourd'hui à quelque chose de
délicieux et caramel ou noix ou pas
voilà une bonne idée ça je suis sûr que
cette fois les enfants aimeront ça
qu'ils m'ont fait goûter à mais bien sûr
sois prudent autres quand même tu
préfères ce au beurre d'anchois ont su à
la crème d'escargots tu veux pas
vraiment eu et incorrigible casimir se
doute que les enfants veulent manger de
thé caramels au beurre d'anchois et moi
je doute même que dû arriver en vendrait
seul qu'est-ce que ça alors vous bottez
tous les deux mois le coup tu as
vraiment complètement borné tu veux rien
comprendre
d'ailleurs si nous disons que nous avons
des doutes sur le succès de tavan c'est
pour ne pas être méchant j'en ai assez
que vous doutiez de tout ce que je fais
alors vous n'avez qu'a décidé vous même
de ce que vous voulez que je vende sa
casimir c'est très bien bravo tu
pourrais vendre des millefeuilles l'art
des mille feuilles non des éclairs au
chocolat one on est partout oui j'ai mal
au coeur des meringues des meringues
aroui des belles montagnes toute blanche
vous croyez que les enfants aimeront ça
comme ça tu vois on n'a aucun de ces
requins bon bah alors je cours cherchait
démoralisant eux monsieur du snob le
président de la fête
on a sûrement dans sa réserve bon j'y
vais d'accord
[Musique]
la voilà enfin emma casimir ça fait
vraiment plaisir de te voir vendre aux
fins de bons gâteaux
je dois dire que ça a l'air familier
bien moi j'ai des doutes à quel propos
qu'est ce qui te nuit je doute d'arriver
à à vendre ses gâteaux pour gagner les
différents comme monsieur du sne homme
demande à bout mais c'est simple écoute
casimir du vent un front chacune de tes
meringue est aussi tardif au white mais
j'ai un autre doute à propos de quoi je
ne suis pas sûr de reconnaître les
pièces d'un enfant c'est pourtant pas
difficile
casimir regarde bien oui d'accord mais
françois tu es bien la laisser là comme
ça je serai sûr d'une femme trompée
bobos mais si ça peut te faire plaisir
quasi me tiens voilà merci à france soir
oui qu'est ce que tu veux encore j'ai
encore un doute très bon à propos de
quoi je ne suis pas certain de pouvoir
compter jusqu'à 10 ans mais tu sais très
bien compter d'habitude
et qu'est ce que tu veux que je fasse eh
bien tu pourrais mettre des pièces là en
ligne je remettrai les miennes à côté
comme ça chie mihara pas l'erreur à
bombay coude casimir je veux bien mais
c'est vraiment parce que dieu fait
preuve de bonne volonté en allant
chercher les 'bric' d'accord voyons
d'israël a déjà une deux trois quatre
5 6 7 8 9 et 10 voilà je peux faire pour
toi
parti très bien merci bon tout à l'heure
ouais ap ap tom tom et voilà jeu
complètement
j'adore les meringues bien poivrer tu ne
vas pas pouvoir les foudres mais je ne
veux pas les vendre je vais tout les
manger pour mon petit goûter
ça va être délicieux mais enfin casimir
comme on fera tout pour rendre à de
monsieur du snob lady feront que tu dois
lui donner mais je les ai tum tum les
abonnés déjà quoi on veut cacher mais ce
scandale au sens mais nous ne nous
jetons simplement prêté les dix pièces
de 1 franc afin de t d a traité compte
et maintenant tu dois de les vendre
casimir du bois neuf ans d'écart tout à
l'heure tu doutait de ce que je faisais
fin maintenant tu ne doute de rien que
nenni